if you've been thinking of buying a new
iMac I would strongly suggest that you
hold off because there was a new report
that just came out yesterday from the
Apple supply chain in China
it basically mentioned that Apple is
going to start mass production of a new
23 inch iMac in the third quarter of
2020 which is anywhere from July to
September so we could see release of
this iMac in the fall or maybe towards
the end of the year and while it's not
the topic of this video
the report also included a brand new 11
inch iPad which could be a refresh to
the iPad air so keep that in mind if
you're looking to buy an iPad but let's
get back to the topic of this video the
upcoming 20/20 iMac now from that report
I was able to pull three different
observations or speculations about this
iMac first off if you know anything
about IMAX you'd know that there has
never been a 23 inch iMac before because
the current lineup consists of both a 21
and a half inch and a higher-end 27-inch
iMac and the craziest thing is that the
design of both of those models has not
changed at all since 2012 yes you heard
that right for the past eight years the
design including the display sizes have
not changed
so in my personal opinion if Apple truly
makes a 23 inch iMac this means that
they're going to change a whole lot more
than just the internals and the display
size we could end up seeing a completely
new design now don't expect the design
to change very much since it still needs
to somewhat resemble the well-known iMac
design but I think they're gonna take
the current 21 and a half inch iMac and
simply slim down the bezels for a more
modern look
it could also feature new display specs
like it being brighter or supporting
more colors it could pack an update at
1080p webcam better speakers and
microphones a better cooling system
updated ports on the back and maybe even
a new stand that's more of a square
shape like the one on Apple's new pro
display XDR and while the current base
model 21 and a half
imac comes with a very outdated 1080p
display I'm almost 100% sure that the
new model will come standard with a 4k
display the point is that it's going to
get a new design for the first time in
eight years and that's something worth
waiting for
even if you have to wait until December
and there have also been some rumors of
Apple coming out with a new mini LED
display for the iMac but that report
also mentioned that there has been
supply chain issues so we may not see a
mini LED model until 2021
but who knows Apple might be able to
pull it off this year now on to my
second speculation the refresh will also
come with updated internals which will
include at least quad core 10 gen intel
processors compared to the current base
model which has an ancient dual core 7
gen chip will get much faster integrated
graphics performance faster 3733
megahertz RAM and upgrade to Wi-Fi 6 and
Bluetooth 5 connectivity and most
importantly we could see the end of the
hard drive now there's a good chance
that the base model will still come with
a once here by fusion drive but
everything above that should hopefully
come with an SSD and there's also a
pretty good chance that you'll be able
to upgrade one of the higher-end 23 inch
models to an 8 core CPU and maybe even a
low-end dedicated graphics card but
that's not very likely since Apple would
want to keep that reserved for the
larger size iMac so we not only have the
design to be excited about but much
better internal specs as well and I'm
fairly certain that the base price will
stay around the same plus or minus $100
of the current $1100 starting price now
on to my last speculation of the 2020
iMac if Apple is truly going to update
the lower end iMac model then they will
100% update the higher-end 27-inch model
with a larger display as well but the
question is will it be alongside this 23
inch iMac or will it happen next year
after what we can expect for the new
refresh of the larger iMac
should expect the same changes that I
mentioned earlier but the most important
thing that we should expect is a new
line of Navi graphics cards from AMD and
faster 10th gen 7 nanometer chips from
Intel this will make the iMac an even
bigger powerhouse than before and we
could even see the release of AMD's
long-rumored
big Navi graphics card that is also
rumored to be coming later this year so
hopefully this video ends up saving you
some money and ultimately putting a much
nicer iMac on your desk if you learn
something new go ahead and tap the like
button and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]